[Music]
in the making of Django you had a bad
accident you were training for all the
horse riding that you had to do and you
were thrown off the horse and badly hurt
yeah unfortunately I broke my pelvis in
it broke your pelvis yeah and but now I
beep at the airport did you really get
it you got a you got a hand in there no
no I got a plate and screws and oh my
god what do you call that bionic yes
you're Bionic now yeah move it more
machine than man equal parts about 50/50
I would just think that would make it
this happened before you even started a
film and then you have to be on a horse
for a lot of the movie and I would think
it'd be hard to to get back on the horse
again true really true it was not only
uncomfortable I admit that I was a
little scared my horse is very big and
I'm you know sort of a regular person
yeah and anyway so so the first the
first canter the first gallop I was
afraid of but then I had these wonderful
teachers and trainers and and friends
helping me support me Jamie gave me a
saddle with a seat belt
terrific
he really did he gave me this big
beautiful saddle and there was a seat
belt on with a buckle and everything you
know the great but also had a shoulder
harness in the hole well we have a clip
here from Django Unchained I believe
this is relatively early in the film
it's not long after you've met Django
and he doesn't really know what you're
up to and I think that you are I believe
you're explaining your profession in
this clip let's see all right let's take
a look first
Estate places a bounty on a man's head I
track that man I find that man I kill
that man after I've killed him I
transport that man's corpse back to the
authorities sometimes that's easier said
than done
I show that corpse to the authorities
proving yes indeed I truly have killed
him at which point the authorities pay
me the bounty so like slavery it's our
flesh for cash business was it bad it's
like a reward you kill people and they
give you a rule with certain people yeah
I'm happy
ah better they are being at the reward
[Applause]